in a coal mine an advanced
state-of-the-art repair robot is
currently inspecting the rail system for
trains that shuttle mining workers
through the mine while inspecting a
control switch that can direct a train
on to one of two different rails the
robot spots for miners in a train that
has lost use of its brakes and its
steering system the robot recognizes
that if the trend continues on its path
it will crash into a massive wall and
kill the four miners if it is switched
on to a side rail it will kill a single
miner who is working there while wearing
headsets to protect against a noisy
power tool facing the control switch the
robot needs to decide whether to direct
a train towards the single miner or not
so first question what would you do if
faced with this dilemma would you direct
the train towards the single miner could
we see the hands of all of those who
would say yes they would direct the
train toward the single miner could we
see the hands of all those who would not
direct the train towards a single miner
it looks like it's not quite as many but
a good number it's an impossible and
painful thing to think about I don't
even know how to get a robot to think
about what this result is but let's go
to the second question what would you do
if the single person who is at risk was
a child would your choice change or
would you still direct it what your
choice change means not directed towards
a single person if that miner was a
child
how many would change their choice
commands are going up they don't to see
the child hurt but not as many how many
would not change their choice oh that's
a lot many more hands went up it hurts
my brain to have to think about thinking
about how to think about that
um annulled mana morality Mehta morale
meta morality and what does that mean
that's a very interesting term idly
maybe I've just coined that but I mean
thinking about thinking about your
morality like not not the the morality
itself but thinking about the rules that
you would use in order to make the
holiday or something like that
right well um mattias you've done a
study on this problem haven't you yes
tell us about it we did a study with my
colleague Bertram Marlowe from Brown
University where we effectively we
didn't show the subjects the video just
saw that's just for demonstration
purposes but we gave them a narrative
along those lines and but we were
interested in comparing was if that
person on the switch was a human Howard
subjects judged the action that that
person performed so different from the
audience question you just got which was
a how would you act we actually said
that person pushed the switch was that
permissible was it morally right and how
much blame would you give to that person
for doing that or the person might not
have acted and then we would ask exactly
the same questions and then we're very
interested in understanding how does a
human in a dilemma like situation like
that compared to a robot how would
people judge a robot performing the
action and what we found was the lots of
studies that have similar outcomes for
the human case if the human does not act
so first of all the action is
permissible most most of you chose to
act if the human does not act the human
doesn't get blamed as much as when the
human gets act when the human does act
but with the robot the situation is
actually reversed well we expect the
humans to not act because we think it's
morally wrong we think it's morally
wrong for the robot to not act in but
we've therefore found is that people
expect machines to act now for us that's
a problem because that means we actually
have to understand dilemma like
situations like that if that is the
expectation behalf of machines
you